you may or may not have already done
calculus and for those of you who have
done it it might seem like a really
difficult subject I struggled a lot with
in high school maybe you find it hard to
recall what it was about the funny thing
is though the actual idea behind
calculus is really easy and familiar
it's all about approximation let me
demonstrate let's look at the classic
problem in calculus finding the slope of
a graph say you want to know how steep a
certain point is on a curve the curve
could look like anything so why don't we
start with an easier problem the slope
of a straight line this is
straightforward in this case the formula
actually more like the definition of
slope is rise divided by run let's
return to our original problem and use
our newfound knowledge to tackle it
let's draw a straight line from A to A
close five point and figure out how
steep that line is to get an
approximation of the actual slope at a
well that looks kind of rubbish so let's
try again with the closer point even
worse okay how about another one and you
see this one's not too bad actually the
points really close to a seem to give
really really close looking
approximations so what's the actual
slope calculus basically says the
obvious thing the actual steepness of
the curve at a is the number our
approximations are getting close to what
about our other classic calculus problem
the area under a curve we have the same
issue here this could be any graph and
we don't have formulas for those the
only area I really know off by heart is
the area of a rectangle so let's use
rectangles in why not guess the area of
the curve like this divide off the graph
like this and then draw a straight line
from the curve to the right now we can
just find out the area of each of these
bits okay so that's not an awful
approximation I guess but there are all
these hanging out bits and missing stuff
well we can make a better approximation
why not divide up the curve smaller see
the arrow gets smaller too so we keep
slicing smaller and calculus tells us
that
area we're limiting to is the one we
want there are lots of other problems
that can be solved by calculus in a
similar way I'll talk about some more in
other videos on this topic but now I
want to bring up an issue with this
whole thing let's go back to the area
under the graph stuff there's another
seemingly better approximation I could
have done why not instead of using
rectangles use these things called
trapezoids they have a very simple area
formula as well and as you can see the
error is way less these are better
approximations so won't they give a
better more accurate answer for the area
well the trapezoid way gets you close to
the actual answer very quickly but both
ways will limit towards the same area in
the end as you divide the graph up
smaller and smaller still this is a bit
worrying if there are better and worse
approximations are there some
approximations that are so bad they're
wrong I'm sorry to say that there is
we'll be seeing a really surprising
example next time see you on the other
side